[Music]
[Applause]
as Kevin Durant is now a member of the
Phoenix Suns as we bring in the great
reporter Sports Illustrated senior
writer Chris Mannix how big of a
surprise is this that Duran's Durant's
now in Phoenix Chris
it's it's a pretty big surprise
um you know the Nets in making the Kyrie
Irving trade they have been operating
like a team that for at least the rest
of this season was trying to see what it
could do with with Kevin Durant they had
other offers
for Irving specifically with the Lakers
that might have brought back more in
terms of draft Capital but the Mavericks
deal you know gave them NBA talent I
mean Spencer Dinwiddie 18 point per game
scorer Dorian Phoenix Smith is one of
the best Wing defenders in the NBA So
the plan in the aftermath of the Irving
trade was to kind of try to see what
they can do with Durant and a bunch of
high quality role players that really
changed in the last 24 hours maybe less
in with with the sons being the
aggressor with their new owner Matt
ishbia really wanted to make a splash
and you know coming to the table with an
offer for Kevin Durant that was more
significant and gave the Nets more than
what they wanted uh last summer so you
know it to get this deal done I think
you've got to give credit to the new
ownership in in Phoenix for really
pushing to make something like this
happen and they also didn't have to give
up DeAndre ayton and I don't know if he
wants to stay in Phoenix he and Monty
Williams have had their moments there
but I don't think that I I just don't
think the Nets wanted DeAndre Aiden I
really don't know I think they could
have had the Andre I think they could
have had DeAndre last year
um look the player they wanted was
Mikhail Bridges I mean Mikhail Bridges
is a modern NBA Talent
um you know he's a long Wing player
maybe you know one of the top you know
top two or three best defensive players
in the league on a man manageable
contract for the next I think four years
three four years they wanted Mikhail
Bridges and they wanted every draft pick
the sons could give up and that's that's
exactly they got exactly what they
wanted in this deal
all right explain the Lakers situation
you don't get Kyrie it felt like Darvin
ham and Russell Westbrook were playing
nice until the other night when they had
words with one another and now he's in
Utah you get DeAngelo Russell but I
looked at the DraftKings odds to win it
all the Lakers odds didn't change one
bit so uh how dangerous are the Lakers
well they they should have changed
because I think the Lakers did a
fantastic job over the last week leading
up to this trade deadline
um beginning with acquiring rui
hashimura who kind of stabilizes that
small forward position in the starting
lineup and then Dan they went out and
finally realized that to build a
successful team around LeBron James's
Talent you need shooting this is
something that Miami did this is
something that Cleveland did and for the
last couple of years it's the kind of
thing the Lakers downplayed as being as
being necessary with their signings and
the trade of Russell Westbrook or for
Russell Westbrook now they get some guys
you know from Utah like Malik Beasley he
can really shoot ruyashimura from
specific spots on the floor he can
really shoot D'Angelo Russell in January
Russell shot 40 from three this month
he's right around 43 percent from three
he's really coming alive with that jump
shot they are a decidedly better team
now than they were a week and a half ago
and look you don't want to use the
cliche of you don't want to play LeBron
in the playoffs well LeBron with a
healthy Anthony Davis and this group
around him you know with enough time to
kind of come together I think they've
got it they're going to be I I think
they're going to be a really dangerous
team in the postseason explain to me how
Kyrie and Luca work together
I think they'll work fine offensively
um you know look Kyrie made it work
albeit in a brief period with James
Harden and Kevin Durant and with just
Kevin Durant you know Kyrie can play off
the ball he's an excellent you know
catch and shoot player uh and there's
only so many shots that Luca Dodgers can
take and look I've been to several
Mavericks games this year but you could
see the frustration on the face of Luca
at varying points during the games
because he was having to do everything
now maybe the minutes can tick down a
little bit maybe you know he doesn't
have to be you know the 22 second per 24
second shot clock guy every single
possession Kyrie's going to take a lot
of stress off him offensively the
problem is
they are going to be deplorable
defensively like you've got Kyrie and
Luca who at best are average Defenders
you've got Christian Woods still there
for now but we'll see what happens in
the next five or six hours
um your three best offensive players are
not good defensive players and generally
speaking that's not a recipe for success
in the postseason they're going to have
to average 130 again they're going to
have to have a we're going to outscore
you because if you need a critical stop
that ain't happening with the Dallas
Mavericks
well it's also Dan I mean it's not to
swing it back to Phoenix but that's kind
of the question mark there too right
like they just traded away Bridges uh
cam Johnson was a good player for them
um and I don't really know what they're
left with there like there's some weird
lineups they're gonna have to throw out
there now they're gonna score a lot of
points too and Durant and Booker are as
good a one-two punch in the NBA Chris
Paul is is the right point guard to kind
of meld all that together but Chris
Paul's not the defender he used to be
Kevin Durant's a good Defender Booker's
a okay Defender good you know average
Defender like that's a team that that I
think especially in the first couple of
weeks of his experiment is gonna have
some nights where they're giving up a
lot of points who would have thought Ben
Simmons would be the last guy standing
with the Nets uh do you think that they
tried to trade him include him in uh any
trades
well I I don't that that's to say that's
a poison pill in trades of being
understated but I just there's no market
like what there's no
there's never like he's physically not
able to prove he can stay on the floor
when he's out there he still won't shoot
um he's not the defensive player that he
used to be there's just he's got you
know one of the worst contracts now in
the NBA maybe the worst contract in the
NBA
um nobody's acquiring at the moment
maybe I mean look we say this all the
time like maybe now with a lesser role
Ben Simmons will play better maybe now
with a bigger role Ben Simmons will play
better but if you think about it Dan
even on this now gutted Nets team
where do you rank Simmons in terms of
best players like fifth
he's he's still not among the top five
or six guys or maybe sixth or fifth or
sixth on that roster right now so the
rebuilding of Ben Simmons is is gonna
have to continue because nobody out
there was or is interested in trading
for him I'll leave you with this with
the sons making the move with Kevin
Durant your favorite right now in the
NBA to win it all is
oh I I I still think it's going to come
out of the Eastern Conference and
I I'd hedge a little bit just say Boston
or Milwaukee I think those two teams
have been the most consistent I'd say
Boston Milwaukee didn't exist because
Boston I think beats everybody else but
they have problems with the Bucks and
have had problems with the Bucks over
the last couple of years and I look I
think Milwaukee's still got a deal to
make two in the next few hours they have
been doing everything possible to
extract Jay Crowder when he was with
Phoenix
I think they're going to find a way to
get him out of Brooklyn in some kind of
deal because the Nets have no use for
him at this point you put Jake Crowder
and if he's still able to play you know
having missed the entire season at a
high level that's going to be an upgrade
for them so it's one-on-one a Boston
Milwaukee to win the whole thing
um however you want to rank them always
good to talk to you we miss you and we
hope you're doing well Chris no you
don't no you don't no you don't you
don't you don't you never call you never
write this is like I even like deleted
prissy's number from my phone I just saw
his area code pop up so you know that's
that's that is that is pandering Dan
that's straight pandering we reached out
to you earlier this season and you
weren't available
no I I think I'd need I need you to make
a whiteboard list of the NBA insiders
you've called before me like was was I
like the fourth guy on the list
let me NBA Radio guys let me ask hold on
Paul uh Paulie uh do you know if Mannix
was the first guy we called today do you
want me to be nice or want me to be
truthful be truthful third okay you were
third yeah
we're talking about it's like what would
you know you know in Chris Haynes those
are big shots easy easy easy
Maddox knows we love him
whatever like I said to Rich Eisen I'm a
Rich Eisen guy now so I'm I'm like
officially Rich Eisen
okay there's a t-shirt why did you come
on today again if you're a Rich Eisen
guy
I just you know to be respectful and uh
I enjoy our conversations and but you
just disrespected me by being respectful
to me
no no I'm I'm pointing out the level of
disrespect I gotta go Chris Hayne Chris
Haynes is on hold here I gotta go I've
been waiting like 10 minutes thank you
Chris you called the wrong Chris yeah
that's Chris Mannix Chris Mannix Sports
Illustrated senior writer